well I'm obviously not going to start as
a government minister commenting on
specific companies and their tax affairs
that will be a matter for HMRC but if I
can make a general point which is that
wherever there is a company and an
individual who is out there avoiding or
evading tax an HMRC will be after them
and we have a hugely positive record in
that respect 160 billion pounds brought
in since 2010 in clamping down on
avoidance 2.8 billion of it in relation
to individuals trying to haul a pipe
money overseas and we actually have one
of the lowest tax gaps in the world I
the amount that we're collecting is very
close to the total amount that we should
be collecting and that's important of
course not least for our public services
nonetheless when Apple was looking
around for alternatives to the Irish
Republic it's considered bermuda the
cayman islands the British Virgin
Islands Jersey Guernsey the Isle of Man
what all those places have in common
well what they have in common or not
what matters is if any company is having
common the fact that they are
aggressively avoiding taxation or
evading taxation in other words not pair
paying the amount that they should be
taking and paying then we will be after
them and we have resourced HMRC
accordingly an extra 800 million pounds
in 2015 to chase down and expect it 7.2
billion in extra avoidance money that
will be bringing in so I can't comment
on individual companies it would be
inappropriate for me to do so but I can
assure you that where there is misgiving
and inappropriate behavior going on that
we will be tracking that down of the
2100 largest companies in our country
around half of them are under
investigation by HMRC at any one time
that doesn't mean to say they've been
doing anything wrong but it means they
have complex tax affairs and it is right
that we make sure that the right amount
of tax is being paid and yet it remains
the case David Cameron was calling for
public registers in these British
overseas territories more than three
years ago why hasn't it happened what
matters is not whether registers or
information is so much public to
everybody I mean my tax returns not
public to everybody and nor is my will
and
a testament but what does matter is that
the tax authorities have access to that
information where it's appropriate so we
have been right at the vanguard of the
OECD initiative the base erosion and
profit shifting project we brought in
new measures involving the transfer of
information between over a hundred
different finances and their financial
centers to make absolutely certain that
HMRC has the tools at its disposal to
look into those places and find those
who are not paying their fair share but
how do you feel when the UK as it has
been is described as the global hub of
tax avoidance that's not a good look for
our country is it well I I don't believe
that that's the way the rest of the
world sees the UK I think when people
think of the UK actually they think of
public spirits I think they think of
fairness and fair play and that's
exactly what we are enforcing through
HMRC within the tax environment because
what we get is a government is that the
people in this country expect everybody
to pay their fair share and as I've said
we bring in 160 billion pounds since
2010 we're investing heavily in NHMRC
we're bringing in their changes to
international rules and regulations to
make sure that they have the tools at
their disposal to track these
individuals and these companies down and
make sure that this money is raised for
our public services